[Music]
get back tomorrow
i don't even like to say it because i'll
be arrested we need
we need to go i'll say it all right we
need to go
in to the capitol
so on the sixth we saw all of these
different
wings of the right humanon adherents
christian dominionists
mega people like normal like just
hardcore supporters of the president and
we saw
out and out neo-nazis getting closer and
closer wound together over
their mutual desire to overthrow the
elected government
which they all see as a legitimate they
all
want to do violence to their political
enemies you can see shades of it within
rush limbaugh
there cannot be a peaceful coexistence
of two completely different theories of
life
theories of government theories of how
we manage our affairs
tucker carlson where we allowed blm and
antifa to destroy
our country in george floyd's name how
shocked are we that 17 year olds with
rifles decided they had to maintain
order
when no one else would they've all been
urging different chunks of this and
getting people more and more comfortable
with the idea
of trying to overthrow the government in
order to stop the left
they have been trying to provoke a race
they're coming for you
and your neighborhood we're all going to
have to defend ourselves
antifa mob saying that if you don't give
us power we're going to keep terrorizing
your cities they want to destroy
america
it took a village to make this happen
[Music]
so i've been covering the far right
and white supremacist movements for
a few years now since the beginning of
the pandemic i noticed this immediate
sort of gathering in online spaces of
people
who were very against government
shutdowns
calling these these actions tyranny and
organizing themselves into various
groups the so-called
wolverine watchmen were furious over
coronavirus shutdowns the group calls
itself
women for america organizers call for a
full reopening a new group called save
our country which is all about lobbying
for a quick opening of the economies
right after the election we get this a
very large facebook group called
stop the steal stop the steal stop the
steal
a group with some 360 000 members
aimed at delegitimizing the election
process the page was filled with false
claims about voter fraud
and called for boots on the ground to
protect the integrity of the vote
we did see protests with the same
name popping up in various state
capitals
[Music]
[Applause]
there's this interlocking network of
right-wing thought leaders who have been
for years increasingly pushing
for violence on behalf of this insurgent
conservative movement but now it's time
to act on the enemy
people need to have their battle rifles
and everything ready at their bedsides
this is it i'd put the heads on pikes
right
i put them at the two corners of the
white house as a warning
to federal bureaucrats that's how you
won the revolution
what can you and i do with state
legislature besides killa
although we should not do that i'm not
advising that but i mean what else do
you do right
when you start seeing that language
being taken very literally on social
media
and different forums to me that's a very
clear red flag
for example this one post from this
website on my militia which i've been
following for a while now somebody
writes i say
take the hill or die trying i don't know
how much more explicit you can be
posts and comments even even on
instagram
saying violence is necessary and these
are just
you know two examples of a sentiment
that has been expressed
over and over no one has any excuse to
be surprised
by what happened on the sixth it was
signposted in places like salem
[Music]
i mean i had my hand broken by a proud
boy at a massive thousand person street
fight
that the police didn't even show up at
one of the key organizers of the left
wing counter protest to unite the right
she was assaulted by a mob of neo-nazis
we are surrounded on all sides one of
the people in that mob
who assaulted her he's a popular white
nationalist live streamer
[Music]
he was present at the capitol on the
sixth inciting people to storm the
capital dude we're
in the capital right now
[Applause]
[Music]
when you're asking about like what were
the signs how did this develop
it developed exactly the way that
anti-fascist activists have been warning
it has been
four years these people are drawing a
movement to them and inciting
violence around the country and
eventually it will burst in some way
that's too big to ignore
it finally did
you